were the undisputed stars are the best  conference in all of football yeah how  about a cheers do their your God huh  writers are back baby back in black  Karan Cooper and Crabtree making the AFC  feel badly people waking the rater  nation the team from the 70s will you  carnation back in black and we make it  look easy  Cooper catches car call an ac/dc come to  the black hole we make enemies waiters  break record especially for penalties  Oakland Raiders Reagan records without  Laila several Kapoor famous if we move  to Las Vegas Raiders belong in the five  one out Davis and the waters gonna tell  me when the guy I'll be catching hell of  miss scoring hell appears I'm a player  getting it but they won a bloat of  whiskey just win baby got four stomachs  Leah bumps and I got five on it cuz I'm  staying and oh-oh